[Music]
imagine that the sun is on the verge of
exploding
or that a planet killing asteroid is
headed our way
or maybe you just want to take the
entire planet on a joyride around the
universe
well fasten your seat belts let's pilot
spaceship earth out of our solar system
what would it take to free our planet
from the Sun's gravity
what out of the box ideas would actually
be the most efficient
and why would you need to destroy nearly
everything on Earth to make this work
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we turned Earth into a
spaceship
it's not totally surprising why many
people refer to our home as spaceship
earth
this giant object carries a crew of 8
billion travels through space at 108 000
kilometers per hour and comes equipped
with some pretty incredible oxygen water
and food production systems
but just moving in One Direction around
the Sun year after year gets a little
boring if only there were ways to get
this nearly 6 billion trillion metric
ton vessel to a high enough velocity
that it could Escape its orbit and the
solar system once and for all
all we'd need to do is crank up Earth's
speed to 151
000 kilometers per hour
we'll try a few conventional methods as
well as some that might surprise you and
hopefully we won't completely destroy
the whole planet in the process
the most obvious way to do this would be
the one most widely used today for
propelling spaceships chemical Rockets
launching one single 500 metric ton
rocket kick-started by a chemical
reaction into space could use as much as
112 kilograms of fuel
so the amount you'd need to launch Earth
out of orbit would be well simply out of
this world
to escape our Sun's gravitational pull
you you need the thrusting power of
billions upon billions of rockets
and powering these Rockets would require
so much material that our planet would
nearly disappear
I mean would it be worth the effort if
you were only left with 15 of the earth
you started off with
Fusion Rockets
for this you'd need to jump on board a
concept that's only a work in progress
Earth's trip would be powered by the
same process that powers our own Sun
instead of chemical reactions Fusion
Rockets would rely on the nuclear fusion
of two or more hydrogen atoms to form
helium
at the very least these Rockets would be
twice as efficient as chemical Rockets
they would make space missions to Mars
about half as long and the journey from
Earth to Jupiter could be as short as
two years
efficiency aside it would still require
enormous amounts of fuel to move any
object as big as ours on the bright side
if hydrogen was your only fuel source at
least it would be widely available
throughout space
ion engines
the next option would be a strong
Contender for powering spaceship earth
if you don't mind a slow and steady wins
the race mentality
an electrostatic ion engine works by
taking accelerated positive ions and
ejecting them at high speeds
one ion engine would deliver about 10
times more thrust compared to a chemical
rocket and while a chemical rocket could
only burn for a few minutes an ion
engine could be steadily powered for
months even years
now the trade-off is slower acceleration
but this would eventually see Earth
reaching the velocity we'd need to
escape the clutches of our sun
solar sails
maybe what you really need to power
Earth through the galaxies would be a
traditional renewable energy source so
why not imagine that you could Propel
your massive spacecraft using solar
power
solar sails would essentially work just
like sales on a boat except instead of
wind
huge reflective sales would capture the
momentum of photons emitted by the Sun
and other stars
as long as you don't run out of light
you'd keep moving
this is based on the principles behind
light sail 2 a mission that was launched
in 2019
The Vessel used a sale about as big as a
parking lot
and it reached the speed of an airline
jet after one month of constant sunlight
but keep in mind that light sail 2 only
has a mass of 5 kilograms and is only
trying to stay in orbit imagine how huge
a sale you'd need to move the entire
planet
and not only that but you'd be at risk
of losing velocity as fewer and fewer
photons hit the sail between Stars
so maybe light wouldn't be the primary
fuel source you'd want to power Earth
through the universe
[Music]
gravitational slingshot
you could power our massive spacecraft
using the gravity of other objects in
the solar system like planets asteroids
or comets
you could increase decrease or change
the direction of Earth's velocity by
slingshotting around these objects this
is exactly what the Voyager 2 space
probe used to escape the Sun's gravity
and leave the solar system but to do the
same for Earth you'd have to start by
deflecting large Rocky objects from the
outer regions of the solar system toward
us
as they approach their orbital energy
would decrease and hours would increase
moving us further away from the Sun
but in order for this to work these
objects would need to basically brush
right up against Earth's atmosphere and
they would need to be big
maybe up to 10 000 times bigger than
what hit Earth millions of years ago and
wiped out the dinosaurs
so while this would be another great way
to increase the speed of spaceship earth
one small miscalculation could lead to
the death of every living thing trying
to enjoy the ride
maybe we'd be better off if Earth wasn't
a spaceship you could control but a
rogue Planet moving freely through the
solar system and beyond
well that's a story
for another